no perdamos minutos nos quedamos minutos
espero que los aplausos se despierten
gracias por estar aquí gracias te the
export convocarme como algunos de
ustedes saben o casi todos saben me
llamo osvaldo cattone pero mi padre no
sé por qué motivo me puso un primer
nombre inocencio
o sea que yo me llamo inocencio osvaldo
cattone pero por supuesto traste toda mi
vida de un rango
de bordo porque me parecía en el colegio
por ejemplo en el colegio primario me
tomaban el pelo con papel y más de una
vez con alguno porque en realidad yo
debía haberme llamado no se debían 666
luzbel satán pero de inocencio no tenía
nada pero una venganza una venganza
porque a los 20 años me fui a estudiar a
italia teatro donde ingresé a la
academia nacional de teatro de roma y de
pronto mis compañeros me decían porque
éste jamás osvaldo cattone el que yo
decía todo el mundo
ocultaba el inocencia y el si te llamas
y noche eso es un hombre muy
aristocrático 11 papás se llamaban en 80
entonces yo descubrí en italia que
llamarse y noche eso es de una gran
pobreza y ya me sentía un medición
borgia
me sentía que yo formaba parte de la
familia papal y a cualquiera que
representaban decía y noches o ratones
mucho gusto o lo cual de pronto nos
damos cuenta que los nombres dependen de
la de actitud y dependen también de la
educación y de la cultura mi papá
también cometió otro error conmigo adoro
a mi padre por favor pero de todas
maneras cometió los cometemos todos este
cuando parece que mamá mi mamá tuvo un
embarazo muy complicado muy complicado
y yo tardé mucho en láser y cuando la
partera para que ni a hablar de cesárea
estamos hablando del año 33
yo nací el 17 de enero de 1933 tengo 85
años y no pongas esa cara tengo 85 años
qué vamos a hacer y creo que hay un
dicho que dice que cumplir años y es
obligatorio y ser viejo es opcional
bueno y resulta que cuando
[Aplausos]
resulta que cuando fue el parto la
partida en mi casa no se usaba la
clínica además éramos muy pobres de
clínica ni se hablaba en nazi en mi casa
con una partera y nació este chanchito
de 4 kilos y mi papá se desmayó tuvo una
emoción muy grande porque el embarazo
venía mal y no sabíamos que podían no
sabían ellos que podía pasar y se fue a
ser borracho con sus amigos con sus
parientes y me anotó una semana después
o sea que yo soy el 17 de enero
capricornio papá ganó el 25 de enero
acuario de una mezcla nada y además me
trajo muchos problemas de gales donde
legalmente mi pasaporte en mis
documentos figuró como 25 pero a veces
en el avión cuando pongo siempre pienso
que nací el 17 y una vez casi no me
dejan entrar a eeuu porque decían que
estaba loco que estaba variando las
fechas de nacimiento bueno todo esto lo
cuento un poco para entrar en materia
ya dije cuando
el ex perito convocó para esta charla el
que voy a hablar en 15 minutos 18
minutos no se puede hablar de mucho en
profundidad es muy difícil entretener al
auditorio y al mismo tiempo de
entretenerlos aportar algo a la cultura
entonces dice hacer algo de teatro de la
historia del teatro es muy largo es muy
curioso el trato tiene dos mil años como
convocamos y conversamos dos mil años en
15 minutos entonces estaba un día en mi
casa yo vivo fue la de lima para estar
en contacto con la naturaleza tengo
montones de animales mascotas gatos
perros tortugas la serie de me encanta
el zoológico y este cuidar a los
animales tengo una pasión por los
perritos abandonados y los gatos y la
injusticia que hay sobre ese problema
pero es otra es otra conversación
resulta que yo estaba en el jardín
tirado haciendo nada porque la gente
cree que yo soy energético que soy muy
dinámico pero lo que más me gusta es no
hacer nada
y lo que más me gusta es estar sentado
mirando un árbol mirando el mar porque
vivo frente al mar y de pronto sentí una
gran paz
sentí una gran herida de una soga
no hago meditación pero sentí que hay un
gran equilibrio entre la naturaleza y yo
o si aquello me integraba a esa
hermosura de plantas de césped de
mascotas durmiendo al sol
y de pronto me sentí muy bien y al
sentirme muy bien es algo de los
pensamientos vuelan uno empieza como a
divagar un pensamiento trae a otro otro
pensamiento trae a otro y se va
mezclando como en una película no tiene
flash backs lleno de recuerdos que
pronto recorrió un poema hermoso de
amado nervo que se llama espacio
pero al recordar el poeta me voy a
sentar porque este lado de la columna su
tiempo
me hace mal me duele la cintura
bueno resulta que estando sentado como
ahora con mis perros y gatos mis
torturas
y recordé un poema de amado nervo que es
un poco la esencia de mi vida y que es
un poco la esencia de todos ustedes y
recorre también con cierta pena o con
cierta sustancia que la poesía está
muriendo
la poesía es como una prima lejana de la
literatura de alguna manera como si la
literatura fuera la reina y la poesía
fuera un duque un conde de la familia
real pero que no es la estrella máxima
de esa familia porque la novela de
ficción tiene un prólogo tiene un
desarrollo tiene un epílogo en cambio la
poesía es como un estallido un óleo
nueva y sáb
es como un fuego artificial que les
puede sorprendernos y de admirar nos cae
y recordé
pensando en estas cosas en la muerte de
la poesía y también un poco en la muerte
de la literatura porque cada vez leemos
menos cada vez estamos más ocupados con
la computadora y el celular y nos
integramos menos al mundo de ficción de
los grandes escritores recordé que casi
nadie ya compra un libro de poemas y el
poema es un estallido del alma es un
mensaje del espíritu que nos hace mucho
bien cuando es bueno cuando es realmente
bueno y hugo sin hablarme el siglo de
oro español donde me echaron góngora
lope de vega quevedo cervantes
yéndonos a la poesía romántica del siglo
19 encontramos como todos vamos a
reconocer ahora montones de poetas
maravillosos neruda amado nervo josé
martí y por supuesto nuestro gran
vallejo gabriela mistral alfonsina
storni y juana el ibarburu
yo me preguntaba en mi jardín y eficaz
dónde están los sucesores donde han
quedado esos grandes maestros de la
poesía que ya no tienen que los siga es
probable que haya mucha gente ahora que
escriba poesía pero nadie tiene la
dimensión de esos bates maravillosos que
marcaron toda una época borges por
ejemplo y recordé un poema en paz y al
recordar lo dije
cuando uno lee algo
no entiende realmente lo comprende
porque aquí me parece que la palabra
clave de este momento de este siglo no
es como en el hippismo disa lab amor
amor me parece que la palabra clave de
esta época debiera ser comprensión
comprendemos porque si comprendemos lo
que nos pasa comprendemos al otro si
comprendemos al otro es probable que
comprenda a otro y de lo particular se
puede llegar a lo universal
yo creo que partiendo realmente de la
base de la comprensión de algo podemos
ser más buenos podemos cambiar nuestra
vida ser más tolerantes y menos
agresivos a mí me parece que ya la gente
en general lee el periódico
lee un poema lee un libro y no entiende
entiendes
el grueso entiende lo general pero lo
comprende realmente le sirve de algo lo
que está diciendo así que eso quisiera
decirte es el poema y después ver si lo
hemos comprendido realmente llevándolo a
otras palabras el poema dice así
muy cerca de mi ocaso
yo te bendigo vida porque nunca me diste
ni esperanza fallida ni trabajos
injustos ni pena inmerecida porque veo
al final de mi rumbo camino que yo que
el arquitecto de mi propio destino que
si extraje la hiere o la miel de las
cosas fue porque en ellas puse yen o
bienes sabrosas cuando plantee rosales
consiste siempre rosas cierto a mí no
salías va a seguir el invierno más dura
me dijiste que el tiempo fuese eterno
pase sin duda largas las noches de mis
penas más no me prometiste tú solo
noches buenas y en cambio de algunas
santamente serenas a me fui amado el sol
acarició mi faz vida nada me debes vida
estamos en paz
bueno después problema en tal tasa por
favor gracias
muy cerca de mi ocaso yo te bendigo vida
que es muy cerca de mi final muy cerca
de mi muerte muy cerca de mí sánchez muy
cerca de mi límite yo te bendigo bendigo
no creo que un hombre pueda bendecir a
otro el papá puede bendecir pero pienso
que un hombre puede decir yo te
agradezco vida muy cerca de mi final muy
cerca de mi muerte eso te agradezco vida
porque nunca me diste ni esperanza
fallida ni trabajo sin justos ni pena
inmerecida porque todo lo que hice fue
consecuencia de lo que de alguna manera
cosechó 15 cosas buenas me devolvieron
cosas buenas
15 cosas malas me devolvió
esa es a digamos inquietud que puse en
las cosas que no resultaron
porque veo al final de mi rojo camino
que yo fui el arquitecto de mi propio
destino yo soy el edificio que construir
de mí mismo un edificio lleno de
departamentos ocupados algunos
alquilados momentáneamente pero todos
forman parte de este edificio que yo
construí de mí mismo mi bondad y maldad
me envidia me resentimiento mi record mi
talento mi gracia me monde a mi cultura
todo forma parte y salud todo todo todo
lo puse yo dentro de mí mismo
esto que soy yo lo construí yo no me
ayudó a nadie un resultado de sí mismo
un resultado de lo que hace de lo que
siente uno tiene el concepto real que
los hechos que uno produce están en uno
y parten absolutamente de uno aunque
alguien te traicione aunque alguien te
haga daño
no importa es uno el que resuelve cómo
comportarse
bueno
vertiente de prueba de que no porque si
extra helayel o la miel de la cosa de
alguien es lo que le diera una cristo es
una vinagre un vinagre 16 y vinagre es
masculino femenino una vinagre o vinagre
cuando el cristo pidió agua en la cruz
según la leyenda éste le dieron 10 para
para que muriera más rápido de vino miel
para la amarga y la miel
si yo extraje la hiel o la miel dulce la
dulzura de las cosas es porque yo puse y
el miel en sabrosas porque cuando
plantar rosales cosecha siempre rosas
yo no plantee zanahorias y nacieron
rabanitos si yo planté rosa nacieron
rosas y planteó dio nacieron nació odio
y plantar rencor nació rencor eso es lo
interesante
ciertos mismos aneas va a seguir el
invierno la vida no me dijo que iba a
ser siempre joven la vida tiene un arco
la naturaleza tiene un arco las mascotas
los seres humanos las plantas todos
mueren en algún momento en algún momento
no sólo muere se marchita declina
declina y uno termina por
finalizar
el final es para todos para la planta
para mascotas para mí para ustedes para
todos el final y mi final sobre todo
estás cerca yo tengo 85 años estoy en el
túnel de salida podría vivir unos años
más porque por ahora me siento bien me
siento vital puedo pensar pero mi
destino está marcado por el tiempo
evidentemente no
pero tú no me dijiste que el tiempo iba
a ser eterno siempre joven era imposible
pase sin duda largas las noches de mis
penas como no de pronto perdidas y
padres perdí a mi madre le perdí a mi
único hermano tuvo un fracaso en el
teatro y se casting para una película y
no me eligieron eligieron a otro y se
colas para conseguir trabajo en un
estudio de filmación y de pronto me
decían que no había lugar para mí tuvo
en montones de frustraciones ámense me
emparenta mucho con el éxito tu éxito en
el teatro es el que querido y amado por
la gente pero también a veces hice obras
quizás más intelectuales quizás más
profundas y el público me dijo no yo
recuerdo hace poco hice una obra con
yvonne frayssinet bernarda alba' de
federico garcía lorca y el público fue
un ausentismo la gente no la quiso ver
era un gran espectáculo era muy bonito
él estaba muy bien puesto pero la gente
dijo no el público elige evidentemente
no
fue pasé largas las noches de mis penas
pero y seres queridos pero me perdí dos
regatos tres amores también una vez
estuve muy enamorado y de pronto bueno
es una cosa íntima pero encontré a mi
mujer en otra posición con otra persona
y bueno así es así es no tuve que vivir
lo tuve que asimilar lo tuve que sufrir
y en cambio tuve noches altamente
serenas en cambio tuve noches
maravillosas noches es que el público se
puso de pie para aplaudirme noches en
que de pronto tuve un amor fantástico el
sexo me salió mejor que nunca claro esas
noches en que uno se siente pleno que
todo le va bien que todo corre que todo
es suave y que todo es mágico
amén como no fui amado el sol acarició
mi faz
estuve en contacto con la naturaleza
puede conocer el pacífico yo que nací en
el atlántico pude conocer el
mediterráneo pude conocer capri la
creencia me bañé en aguas cristalinas y
hermosas en contacto con la naturaleza
en contacto con el aire libre en
contacto con la libertad
tuve noches fantásticas entonces yo no
soy deudor de la vida la vida no me debe
nada a mí yo solo soy deudor me
equivoque soy yo no soy acreedor eso
quise decir solo tengo derecho a decirle
a la vida en el final de mi vida no
tengo derecho a decirle a la vida
que tengo en el sentimiento que estoy
enojado o porque me tengo que ir porque
la vida fue generosa conmigo porque yo
fui generoso conmigo así que yo me
siento acreedor por ese regalo que he
tenido cuando nació es el chanchito de 4
kilos y mi papá se desmayó bueno yo me
siento acreedor de haber vivido una vida
maravillosa aún dentro de una economía
aún dentro de un problema
problemas legales he tenido problemas de
pareja que he tenido gente que me ha
abandonado gente amigos que me han
traicionado no importa no importa eso
forma parte de la vida nadie me dijo a
mí que yo nacía en este mundo para ser
absolutamente feliz la vida no es
perfecta pero yo lo pasé fantástico aún
dentro del dolor porque fíjense uno el
pronto vuelve del cementerio a enterrar
a alguien y vuelve a dormir y vuelve a
comer y yo era un tiempo hasta que
vuelve a reír uno pierde a los padres
quiere a un amigo y uno vuelve a ir al
cine vuelve a ver una película vuelve a
amar vuelve a reír y así pasa siempre
quiero despedirme porque ya
desgraciadamente el tiempo es tirano y
tenemos que sintetizar y yo soy muy
verborrágico me quedaría todo el día
hablando con ustedes
quería escribirme con una frase de word
whitman no es bueno a veces traducir
poemas el poema de venderse en lengua
original
todos esos poemas latinoamericanos que
hemos leído el lengua original nos dicen
más que una traducción pero hay un poema
hermoso the world will man que dice
cuando haya pasado el tiempo
de esplendor en la hierba no añoraremos
y felices seremos con lo que nos queda
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]